[Musique]
s il en faudrait peu pour être heureux
les amis j'ai reçu un email de mon papa
de monsieur bouchard et cette image ça
peut être tout simplement
photo les amis il ya quatre ans j'avais
fait une vidéo qui s'appelait quand
j'étais petit est innocent si cette
miniature vous dit quelque chose c'est
normal c'est que tu me l'avais
énormément mis en avant à l'époque dans
toutes les suggestions je crois que tu
voulais vraiment que les gens savent à
quoi je ressemblais quand j'avais 10 ans
mon père a retrouvé une nouvelle série
de photos de son fils préféré je suis
trop content d'avoir eu un parent qui
était bonne le photographe lui quand
j'étais plus jeune parce que du coup bah
j'ai une trace de ces années là et ça
m'arrange parce que le dit mon travail
c'est faire des vidéos alors ça me donne
des idées de vidéo facile finalement
merci papa d'avoir pensé à moi je suis
sûr qu'il a fait dans ce but là en plus
aujourd'hui nous allons voir squeeze pré
ado puis squeeze ado j'ai jamais trop
compris la différence dans les deux cas
tu es moche tu as des boutons c'est
parti de mes 12 ans à mes 17 ans voyons
la gueule que j'avais let's go yes ça
fait plaisir en commun sur une photo qui
m'est extrêmement valeur il est vrai
qu'à 12 ans
caractéristiques principales étaient cet
espace entre chacune deux méthodes
contribué à mon charme de l'époque
charme qui atteignait 0 fille âgée
embrasse les deux textos d'une pudeur à
cette époque là il est vrai ma musique
préférée était
[Musique]
suivant [ __ ] mais c'est quoi cet
événement j'ai aucun souvenir de cet
événement tu vois je parlais des trucs
qui m'ont marqué sa bakelants devra
marquer au buffalo et personne ne te
souvenir de quoi ils mangent ou buffalo
ça n'existe pas penser que c'est
possible je m'amuse encore plus que là
sur la photo d'un trait oui c'était
peut-être le nouvel an mais clé wi ont
fait pas toujours le nouvel an avec ses
amis jusqu'à 4 heures du mat ces fonds
le fait que jusqu'à minuit quatre là où
buffalo c'est comme ça on va forcer à
aller là je discutais avec qui voulait
discuter tu as même un cobaye mais c'est
bien les vosges la [ __ ] j'ai changé de
coiffure mec tu étais les 50 ans de mon
papa juste ici et moi c'était mes 12 ans
le jour de mes 12 ans et une fois plus
je rêvais tout simplement pas d'être ici
mais de jouer à dofus ben oui on voulait
que ça à 12 ans arrêté j'arrête pas de
moi mais c'est tellement bien mais je ne
vivais que pour ça vous ne pouvez pas
vous rendre compte mais qu le soir je me
couche est bien vu des points de dégâts
qui s'affichait comme ça je me
réveillais je croyais que je venais de
loot une maîtrise d'armes alors pas du
tout j'avais dormi à les suivants o
alors ça c'était désolé ça fait beaucoup
de visages floutés mais il ya peut-être
des gens qui ont envie de garder leur
vie privée secrète c'était le mariage
des filles de ma belle mère
ah non c'était le mariage toulouse on
bat les couilles plus de sophos enfin
bref c'est un mariage je me fais chier
pour rire à la flora je suis content
j'ai deux fois de plus je fais chier mon
frère en l'exposant dans une de mes
vidéos ça ça me fait plaisir il m'en
parle à chaque fois flandin un très beau
style c'est toi qui m'a été trahi ce
jour la course tu es toi le plus beau et
de l'autre côté de l'image on a un style
un peu plus négatifs
une personne très peu à l'aise dans sa
tenue qui rêve une fois de plus d'être
devant l'office
ce qui est fou c'est que dix ans après
j'ai le même problème je trouve aucun
costume cravate abattage je pense que de
bas ça ne va pas mais qu'en plus ma
corpulence fait que ça me va encore
moins à là on est à l'aise tu es un mec
j'avais des cernes j'avais 12 ans et
j'avais des serbes
j'étais en vacances à ce moment là donc
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils avaient comme
quoi c'est juste que je jouais jusqu'à 5
heures du matin et je mangeais à monza
pour continuer de jouer c'est incroyable
je sais pas quelle serait ta main droite
ou bien les fautes et donc vous savez
pas non plus le bronzage les petits mecs
tu as donc est ce que ça existe encore
c'est des costumes pour en faire donc
c'est un costume pour enfants et ça
m'allait quand même pas regardé il fait
plus froid
maintenant mes parents ont distillé
c'est que du coup aujourd'hui là
maintenant
je sais où acheter un costume qui
taillera bien de 2 à 16 ans ben mec je
penche pour un 15 ans et ça me va gérard
budin commandé un mail champlain le
commander non mais vraiment je veux
savoir c'est un costume destiné un
enfant de 16 ans me va au québec ses
commandes et j'ai acheté un costume
destiné à des enfants de 16 ans voilà
juste pour voir
cherchez pas la suite maintenant
laissez-moi oublier ça le mépris sur ce
visage et florent là c'est pas parce que
tu as un style de mannequin elle que tu
peux me regarder comme ça
calme toi tu fais site était jaloux
parce que j'avais le choix ne bouffent
tout et pas toi bats fallait me demander
de l'apprêter ça je me souviens très
bien c'est le jour mon frère choix il
avait en 2012 mon frère avait 22 ans 22
ans attend c'est à dire que là il avait
l'âge que j'ai maintenant et regardez il
a très peu de barbe ça veut dire gros
dans quatre ans j'aurais zappé barre de
maintenant peut-être eu un bref pendant
deux ans mon frère reçoit son premier
ordinateur un ordi portable et moi en
voyant ça qu'est ce que je me dis je me
dis [ __ ] le fdp
il va pouvoir faire de l'arctique quand
il veut pas ce qui va avoir ça dans sa
chambre j'étais trop jeune
sauf que moi contrairement à mon frère
qui me jugent qu est ce que je fais un
petit regard amical montrant ma
bienveillance envers ce dernier s'est
tout à dia le regard amical se
transforme envisage de la jalousie et en
vrai c'est cool tu en dis parce qu'il
commençait je crois déjà il avait acheté
une tablette graphique qui revient ce
lundi pour commencer déjà dessiné tout
en vrai ça l'a aidé puisque aujourd'hui
c'est son métier évident ça donc très
bon bouffe de la part de mon père de lui
offrir sa faute de là j'ai survolé vite
fait toutes les photos quand je les ai
reçus m'ont pas pour voir s'ils
n'étaient pas les mêmes déjà qu'il ya
quatre ans je suis tombé sur ça du coup
je les directs mais sur instagram suis
vachement sa gamme exclusive de la pêche
au patient s'aggrave et squeeze et c'est
devenu la photo là l'une des photos les
plus laïcs et de mon comté c'est le cas
à tain je crois le plus de gens enfin
bref c'est les gens ont été émus donc je
pense que je n'étais pas seul à mettre
des tonga jouent à dofus à cette époque
par contre j'étais le seul à avoir ni un
casque ou des écouteurs mais avoir un
cas scooter c'est nul à chier n'achetez
jamais ça je jouais mon petit fait cas
les connaisseurs reconnaîtront la map
ozap d'astrub l'amap du dessus c'est là
où il y avait tous les défis hier c'est
là où on clique et des culs et en fait
je regardais des mecs se battre regardez
là je regarde la vidéo d'un mec je sais
pas tu as pris trop de retrouver les
objets dofus evil sadida espère qu est
ce que je vais regarder cette vidéo dix
ans après
rien qui va rien ne va
[Musique]
g
bon en tout cas je rêvais dates et
villes ça dynamise a dit d'asturias
cette vidéo tu m'as envoyé de l'amour
quand j'étais jeune que je n'avais
besoin j'espère que tu as bien toi et ta
famille tu as sûrement une famille à
l'heure actuelle à moins que tu aies
jamais décroché de dofus a regardé des
capus dofus alors il est où le petit
sourire mais quand je me fais chier en
fait 60 ans que j'étais vraiment
extrêmement addict aux jeux vidéo et
même jusqu'à peu en vrille jusqu'à hier
un an là j'étais hyper a dit et là je me
suis vraiment calmé et ça me fait du
bien vraiment mais du coup à l'époque
dès que j'étais pas devant un écran
j'avais cette gueule ou quoi
c'est grave aux attendes il y avait
carlito à mes repas de famille le pull
un peu tectoniques mec j'étais vraiment
étonné qu'un ça je vous jure les damiers
les tous les tons souviens c'était un
peu tectoniques a vraiment l époque
c'était ça ses maîtresses en un an son
passé et comme vous l'avez vu les seules
photos de mon père a pris ces trois
photos de moi devant dofus il y avait un
seul moment où je n'étais pas devant
dofus et faisait la gueule à la regarder
les premiers boutons apparaissent linge
et l'air fatigué m ex un truc deux ans
fait aujourd'hui je trouve que j'ai
l'air tout le temps fatigué mais à
l'époque mec c'était c'était beaucoup
plus abuser un vraiment c'est grave à 13
ans d'avoir l'air aussi fatigué par
contre ce qui est impressionnant aussi
c'est que j'ai 13 ans on dirait que j'ai
dit est ce que c'est bon oh bien sûr ça
va partir en photo de profil ça est je
vous laisse si mon père m'a envoyé cette
photo à l'époque j'aurais mis en face de
profil facebook là je vous trouve style
et même dix ans après je me trouve beau
là dessus les gars bah ouais alors à bas
la barrière
les choses ne sont pas par hasard dix
ans après ça je faisais une vidéo avec
le rédacteur en chef du petit larousse
c'est pas beau ça mais là j'en avais
aucune idée là à ce moment là je pense à
mon bep cap libre regarder ma gueule
regard mais comme je suis perdue [ __ ]
on dirait un mec paumé vraiment j'ai
vraiment l'air fatigué mais regarde mais
c'est pas grave si t'as pas la puissance
de evil sadida lucas c'est pas grave
pense à autre chose oh là là haut ça y
est j'ai changé de mode là ça doit être
deux ans plus tard là il ya un truc qui
a changé à le pal buffalo le buffalo est
toujours là rassurez-vous surtout
regarder la cne commencent à arriver
ah oui oui mais lucas tu es loin de
s'imaginer à quel point elle veut être
présente dans ta vie tu sais pas bon
j'avais fait cette photo à l'époque
parce que je savais que tôt ou tard un
jour j'allais parler d'acné dans ma vie
regardez la cne qui arrive la peau de
plus en plus rouge les boutons de plus
en plus grand et ça me complexe et
beaucoup beaucoup comme tous les gens
qui ont beaucoup beaucoup de boutons
mais sachez que tôt ou tard ils
disparaîtront ces [ __ ] de boot ou un
an je me cache non vraiment vraiment
j'étais pas bien je vous jure déjà je
crois je m'endormais donc c'est
confortable mais aussi j'avais un peu
honte de la cnei tout à la la je fais
que de me cacher je crois qu'en fait du
coup les photos que j'avais du mal parce
qu'après quand je les voyais j'avais
trop d'acné ça me faisait mal à ça me
fait bizarre c'est triste c'est triste
ça commençait vraiment à me complexé
énormément quoi est encore là ça se voit
pas trop mais voilà il ya du bouton quoi
un peu partout oui le chat ne m'ont pas
pas toujours en vie à l'heure actuelle
télé vient doit avoir 11 12
du coup à l'heure actuelle c'est ouf la
miss pasqua là les gars vous avez avait
tout pour être heureux c'est dimanche
matin il fait ce qu'il vous arrive tout
à fait mais je fais une teinture quavec
j'ai les cheveux noirs c'est incroyable
alors c'est quoi qu'est-ce que j'ai eu à
temps un truc d'énigmes pas mal en fait
c'est bien en gros le but de ma famille
c'était d'offrir des cadeaux qu'ils me
fassent sortir des écrans voilà genre
est une énigme ils sont bios un peu
proche des jeux 2
ils ont terrassé écran et banon moi ce
que je veux c'est un abonnement d'un an
à huy magnifique mon set up gaming
pendant trois ans chez mon père c'était
ça mais c'était sur ce pc et que je
monte mes vidéos avec ce clavier cette
souris que je dormais je me levais je
jouais et là je venais de recevoir ma
première carte d'acquisition pour
pouvoir enregistrer du gameplay de
consoles en fait donc si mon père ma
voix faire ça il avait aussi offert ma
première caméra hd on se souvient du
coup la voie là j'étais en train de
l'installer fallait la mettre dans le
pca ne me trompe c'est une carte
graphique c'est pas une carte
d'acquisition je jouais au jeu en [ __ ]
de grosses qualités à battlefield et
oust et c'était génial et je crois le
noël d'après du coup j'ai reçu la carte
d'acquisition qui me permettait
d'enregistrer du gameplay consoles hd et
où j'étais trop content tu vois tout
sale tout ce qu'on est en train de voir
là c'est grâce à cet homme mon pote il
est là le hochart avec son appareil à la
main cette vidéo
les revenus seront versés à mathias
alliés lucas il a 14 ou 15 heures il
sent pousser des ailes il tape une
petite bière label que dans le présent
et je le rappelle il faut être majeur
pour moi remercie mon deuxième set up le
pc que jamais du coup je l'avais donne à
mon père était celui-là et moi avec la
youtube monnaie je m'étais acheté une
tour gaming pour pouvoir fermer montage
avec une fluidité maximale et
enregistrer les gens mega mega hd
j'avais aussi ma petite xbox à cette
amap et un call of duty saillants
n'était sortie de dofus
j'entre et le call of games vous quand
j'allais un week-end sur deux chez mon
père bas je posais matour dans son du
rouge branché l'écran et tout et puis je
il était exclu son bureau finalement pas
là là vous connaissez un là j'ai la
gueule que j'ai dans les dents plein de
vidéos en fait pour l'éviter je crois
que sa saga j'avais coché des podcasts
sommes à un moment et je me retrouve à
prendre la place de mon père et à moi
faire des images de tout le monde pour
que peut-être des années plus tard face
une vidéo où il regarde ces images le
cycle suit son cours c'est magnifique
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère que vous serez pas trop embêté
j'espère que ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas
à aller mais si c'est le cas c'est
marrant comme on a des souvenirs de ces
époques là mais en fait c'est assez flou
et c'est en voyant les photos et les
vidéos qu'on arrive vraiment à souvenirs
en détail de ce qu'on ressentait à ce
moment là en fait je sais que j'ai
commencé à être beaucoup plus heureux et
à savoir un peu plus où je vais quand
j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos en fait
même au tout début même quand ça faisait
200 vue parce que j'avais trouvé le truc
qui me plaisait et
le truc dans le calme un vestiaire même
si j'étais hyper loin de douter de que
la suite salette basque là où je suis
maintenant en fait donc la remercie
parce que vous rendez pas compte mais ça
m'a vraiment fait beaucoup beaucoup de
bien à cette époque et je manque encore
plus quand on voit les images et ça me
faisait vraiment plaisir voilà donc
merci beaucoup pour ça je vous fais
plein de très gros bisous je vous dis à
très dans une prochaine vidéo et attend
est-ce que j'ai reçues le costume ce que
j'ai reçu j'espère si oui bah y'a le
moment d'annoncer loyal ou trop haut là
je vous aime
[Musique]
il est un peu petit jean si ce message
le krach mais mec genre de temps il me
va mieux que tout ce que j'essayais de
ma vie mecque pour mon mariage il faudra
que je commande mon costume sur un site
qui s'appelle les petits mecs sur un
site dont juste le nom me rappelle mon
problème de corps de l'achat
[Musique]